In case you haven't heard,...
...there's yet another social media network launching.
Called Ello, it aims to be the world's first social media site...
...that doesn't track your movements on the net...
...or shove advertisements in your face all the time.
Now, of course there's that other huge network...
...that everyone and their mom, dog, and even some inanimate objects use.
The big FB gets its billions by auctioning off your profile...
...and choices to the highest bidder in exchange for ad revenues.
Ello wants to change that by delivering a transparent, smooth experience.
Their slogan, quote, "You are not a product,"...
...is echoed by the simple design that pushes interaction between friends to the forefront.